one single question has kept Gamers up
for years is chess an esport it's a
hotly contested issue that you're likely
to get a different answer to depending
on who you speak to so we only thought
it was right to sit down and ask two of
the best chess players alive to get
their thoughts but along the way we
realized we might be asking the wrong
thing maybe the real question is are all
Esports just
chess
despite being like a 1500-year old board
game chess seemingly gained New Life
over the last 3 years or so I mean by
now everyone and their mother has a
chest.com rating and some of the biggest
gaming Personalities in the world have
been obsessed with it at one point or
another it's too
soon it's too soon Hikaru we didn't even
reach a climax but what became very
interesting is that since so many of
these quote unquote Gamers were playing
chess online it sort of began taking up
the same spaces as Esports but is chess
a medieval board game an esport well
that all depends on who you ask I
personally don't think so for a whole
bunch of different reasons but to be
fair I'm not an orts Pro or a Grandmas
so to get a more educated answer we sat
down with two of chess's greatest minds
but even they were sort of on the fence
you see Hikaru believes that it all
comes down to whether or not you see
online chess as completely separate from
over theboard chess I mean I think it's
a bit bit of both I think on the one
hand chess isn't esport on the one hand
I don't think it is what I would say is
that in chess especially online there
are a couple of things that are very
different than over theboard first of
all when you when you play online
generally you if you do gain time for
every single move you make it's like one
or two seconds or there's no time added
at all during the game that's something
that in terms of over theboard chest
they're they're actually I can't think
of a single term that you play where
time isn't added when you make a move
you gain time in terms of over theboard
chest and online you don't always gain
time or it's very limited and I think
from that standpoint it makes the game
is much more exciting at the end it also
means like the quote unquote mechanics
of using a mouse or making these pre
moves where you make a move in
anticipation of your opponents those are
things that are definitely along the
lines of an esport um that don't apply
to over theboard chess whatsoever so I
think from that standpoint it can be
like an ort at the same time I think
also it it kind of you know there are
many games where it doesn't get to get
to that stage there isn't the drama of
like a couple of seconds on the clock or
needing the mouse skills in the same
kind of way so I think it's it's it's a
it's a hybrid on one hand it is an ort
on one hand it's not but when we asked
Magnus Carlson he claimed that all of
these distinctions just don't really
matter anymore I think some you know of
the mysticism about Chess was or much of
it was already lost quite a while ago
when uh andin came came along who
basically showed people the score in the
game before that you could never see
what the score in chest was you would
had to sort of have someone to explain
to it now people can see a bar going
going up and down and I think from that
point on chess players sort of cease to
be these um mystical creatures these
magicians who could could create
something nobody could understand so
like I think
once that sort of disappeared I think
it's very good that we just
Embrace um having having more of that
making just more of a uh more of a uh
sport for sure and maybe they're both
right maybe the distinction just doesn't
really matter anymore because regardless
of what your opinion on it is ever since
the explosion of online chess it's
basically been permanently added to the
Esports Zeitgeist and aside from all
that although I don't personally view it
as an ort I do at the very least
understand the connection after all
chess is in a way the origin of all
Competitive Gaming in fact it's sort of
this old Game Dev theory that to make a
good competitive experience you start
with chess expanding adding new rules
and elements every step of the way and
the more you think about it the the more
it starts to make sense and it goes a
lot deeper than just both games require
strategy let's start by taking a look at
Counterstrike as our first example a
game that like chess I consider to be
almost science likee in its gameplay as
we all know chess pieces have their own
specific way of moving in a turn with no
exceptions or bending of the rules CS
although much more Dynamic has a lot of
those same trappings guns have a
specific and absolute spray pattern and
if I throw a smoke in a certain lineup
it's going to land in the exact same
place every every single time I do it
Hey listen it's a bit of a stretch but
you can even make the argument that
economy is like the management of your
pieces on a chessboard and don't get me
started on map control that's chess 101
and just like chess you can play and
grasp Counter-Strike fairly quickly
without having to read a book watch
videos or really even practice but doing
so and learning executes or openings is
going to elevate your gaml tenfold hell
you can even view each weapon or
position on a team as a chest piece
itself obviously CS has a lot more going
on but everything can play a very
specific role on a map and when executed
properly it rarely needs to stray from
its necessary duties once again things
are much more dynamic in Counter-Strike
I think that goes without saying but I
think there's a reason why teams like
astralis had so much success playing a
regimented and mechanical style you
can't tell me after watching Prime
astralis if you break down what they do
tick by tick isn't even the slightest
bit like watching a master play chess
this could be the ticket for astralis
these grenades could do all of the work
for them three of them going over the
wall one on exist one on crims
everybody's Catching Fire twist goes
down and there it is they close it right
out two on four and these arguments
continue to extend to games like league
and DOTA every role has their positions
and limitations a tank is supposed to
absorb damage a control Mage locks down
areas with CC an assassin deletes people
and a skirmisher skirmishes Champions
are simply unique pieces that you can
move and position on a board depending
on their specific strengths and I think
that's exactly why we are now starting
to see a guy like Tyler one excel in
chess think about it he has reached the
highest level in every single League
role despite being a bit of a goofball
he understands the game to a molecular
level and whether he's conscious of it
or not I kind of believe that Tyler is
using his skills in league to win
matches in chess which got him a
respectable plus 14400 ELO in just a
matter of a few months and maybe we can
take something from this if League
actually helped Tyler understand chess
maybe it works the other way around
maybe practicing the oldest ort in the
world can make you better at a game like
CS now one of the most obvious
differences between competitive video
games and chess is the massive increase
in a symmetry I mean no one gets an
AK-47 in chess but those foundations are
just so similar it's hard to ignore and
this isn't even an original thought
there are plenty of videos and threads
of other people comparing esport level
games to chess and I think the reasons
we do that are incredibly clear once
again whether or not chess is actually
an e-port or not is a bit of a moot
point it's become a part of our world
and I don't think there's any getting
rid of it after its first initial boom I
thought that chess was just another
pandemic flavor of the month that people
would move on once things got too
difficult or boring but being the
Eternal competitive game it just keeps
popping back up and I think it's because
its simplified nature scratches an itch
that modern games just can't there's no
ping no exploits no bugs no battle pass
win or lose the outcome is entirely
dependent on your own performance and
despite it being an ancient game I think
that's a breath of fresh air these days
I just can't wait for what the devs are
going to do when they finally drop chess
2 this is the only thing the only time I
will ever consider chess actually being
a video game or an esport is if they
make a geog guess like a geog guessing
game that's like IRL like you get a
picture and you have Thumbtack and then
you have a giant globe that you have to
spin and then you need to place it that
would be like over theboard geoguesser
in my opinion